[Applause]
[Music]
give me
one minute and i'll show you how
filestore can help you manage your file
system
filestore is a managed file storage
service for apps that require a file
system interface and a shared file
system for data
it gives users a simple native
experience for standing up managed
network detached storage
with their vm instances in compute
engine and google kubernetes engine
filestore offers low latency for file
operations
so it's perfect for workloads like data
analytics media rendering
genomics processing or other media
intensive application
you can pick a performance tier and the
storage capacity you need with file
store which enables you to tune your
file system for a particular workload
use cloud console the api or simple
gcloud commands to create a file store
instance
applications across your organization
probably need to access and share common
data sets
you can host file content in file store
and enable shared access to that data
filestar helps creators like graphic
designers and video editors access
shared storage to manipulate and produce
large files
so next time you're looking to manage
files take a minute to look at file
store
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
filestore